technology has been transforming every
aspect of society and that includes
revolutionary new capabilities for
police departments from tattoo
recognition technology to the growing
use of drones these high-tech
innovations are highlighted in the June
edition of Wired magazine here to tell
us about it is their editor in chief and
Nicholas Thompson Nick good morning
morning so let's start with the
technology a lot of people are becoming
more familiar with that's body cameras
how good is that technology now and
where do you see the future with that
heading well the technology is good and
it has been good at possibly reducing
violent interactions between police and
innocent people what's very interesting
and what will come next is facial
recognition software embedded in body
cameras so computers getting much better
at identifying faces and you can imagine
police being able to just put it on scan
the streets and say oh that's a suspect
right that's somebody I need to go talk
to you right now they they're also now I
mean there are systems now to store all
the images from that are being collected
on body cams is that right right so
we're much better not only at collecting
lots of images but also analyzing them
also you can imagine a sort of a mesh
network of all the images taken by all
the policemen looking at them and
looking for patterns and looking for
people and it's not just faces right
well it's also tattoos right all kinds
of things you can look for all kinds of
patterns and images the tattoo thing is
interesting why do I care about tattoos
well because you're gonna mean they are
there are kind of signatures in tattoos
the tattoos can signify certain things
perhaps a gang membership remember all
of this is tied into a big question we
have a Fourth Amendment in this country
against unreasonable searches and
seizures and we have that at the same
time we have this technology where we
can gather massive amounts of new
information and look for very specific
things in it so there is going to be
huge tension over this as there is on
tattoos is a tattoo of form of
expression that should be exempt from
all of this or is it a signal that can
be used to keep the public safe that's a
really interesting and complicated
debate that we're heading right into
yeah that is a really interesting
question well what about drones we keep
hearing more and more about this is
there this increasing concern about the
number of eyes in the sky
yeah so drones are gonna be great for
police departments they're starting to
roll them out right you can imagine
tracking suspects you can imagine them
helping in search and rescue in hostage
situations you can also imagine
flying a whole bunch of them above a
crowd you know and lie there looking for
a specific person or just looking at
everybody and seeing who's there
that could be great you could help keep
us safe it could identify terrorists it
could prevent bad things from happening
or it could be or well in and you know
unreasonable government searches to what
degree is is this is all this new
technology being used to try to
anticipate or predict criminal behavior
yeah so that's the that's the next level
we're starting to see that where police
officers have software or police
departments have software that will tell
them Oh
based on historical patterns are based
on the property crimes we've seen
recently there might be another robbery
on this block why don't you go drive
around it yeah or we've taken all these
factors on different people we've scored
them all and we've said this guy is
possibly going to commit a crime why
don't you go see where he is right now
that is being deployed right now in all
kinds of police departments including
controversially Los Angeles and we're
seeing a police department say this is
great
helps us anticipate crimes keep the
neighborhood safe and you're seeing
people say wait it's just another
high-tech form of profiling and again a
violation of our Fourth Amendment rights
yeah and these privacy concerns are
something that we continue to hear about
a rina cat this inflection point where
you've got these technologies that are
advancing at this record pace and then
people wondering where is all this
leading in where do my privacy rights
actually kick in I think we're driving
right through that inflection yeah yeah
okay all right Nick Thompson thanks so
much all kinds of scary questions being
posed here this morning Nick Thompson
thanks for being with us thank you